This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropic Berry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit, and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.cai at participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. Hey, this is Hayes, Davenport, and Sean Clements.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。全新的红牛龙果味和热带果味能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，采用冻干水果制成，带来爆发的电感风味。全新红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳发售。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，麦当劳.cai的详细信息可在参与活动的加拿大餐厅（魁北克除外）查询。嘿，我是海斯、达文波特和肖恩·克莱门茨。
We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stillard, and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle.
我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。我们与演艺界人士交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能给我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为他们的公关让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多出色的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼、亚当·斯考特、丹尼·麦克布莱德、本·斯蒂勒，以及许多如果没有我们就不可能有今天成就的大人物。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在全新播客《独行女子》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我坐他的摩托车。
I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity. and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”的空间。我的使命是重新定义“独行女子”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《独行女子》。我被囚禁了九个月。我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的境遇中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会和那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺了发声的权力。
These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America, plays out in one small town. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land.
这些是关于为了活着走出来需要付出什么的故事。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。我们的家乡不是试管。在纳什维尔东北部90英里处，一场关于美国未来的争夺战在一个小镇上演。具有右翼背景的开发商已经购买了数百英亩土地。
We need cities on a shining hill. This is Our Town, a podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town
我们需要山巅之城。这是《我们的小镇》，一档关于当一个小镇成为社会实验场并进行反击时会发生什么的播客。我想你们现在没搬进一群愚蠢的乡巴佬中间吧？请收听《我们的小镇》
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上。或您获取播客的任何地方。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. As someone who studied psychology and spends a lot, and I mean a lot of time in psychology research and psychology spaces and therapy spaces, I used to have this terrible habit of psychoanalyzing my romantic relationships, my Tinder dates, my friends Tinder dates, the relationships of people I saw online, of people in my family. It was a terrible habit. And over time, it created this
欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十多岁的心理学。作为一名学过心理学并且花了很多（我是说大量）时间在心理学研究、心理学空间和治疗空间的人，我过去有一个可怕的习惯，那就是过度分析我的恋爱关系、我的Tinder约会对象、我朋友的Tinder约会对象、我在网上看到的人的恋爱关系、我家里人的恋爱关系。这是一个糟糕的习惯。随着时间的推移，它造成了
barrier between me and the people that I met because I was always on high alert for warning signs or what their behavior might mean more clinically or psychologically that I needed to be aware of, that I needed to be alert to. I think these days out, just like collective understanding of psychology and of therapeutic terms like hyper-independent, like emotionally unavailable, like mother wounds and father wounds and insecurely attached, avoid and anxiously attached. Like all of these, our knowledge of them has all just increased. And I think many of us who are actively dating find it very easy to rely on these categories to explain the individuals that we are dating.
我和我遇到的人之间的一道屏障，因为我总是高度警惕警告信号，或者他们的行为在临床或心理上可能意味着什么，这些是我需要注意的，是我需要保持警惕的。我认为如今，人们对心理学以及诸如过度独立、情感疏离、母系创伤、父系创伤、不安全依附、回避型依附和焦虑型依附等治疗术语有了集体的理解。所有这些，我们对它们的了解都在增加。我认为我们当中许多积极约会的人发现，很容易依赖这些类别来解释我们正在约会的人。
If you're somebody who finds dating very anxiety-inducing and scary or you've been hurt before, it feels like a wise decision to overanalyze, psychoanalyze people's behavior and be on the lookout for red flags. It feels like a safe call. But what do we actually lose by doing that? Is it really actually necessarily helpful to look at dating behavior through this lens all the time? And just because we have the language, just because we understand these concepts, does it actually reduce the fact that maybe these people will just show up? And does it actually increase our chances of finding somebody who does match our style of loving and match our way of connecting?
如果你是一个觉得约会非常让人焦虑和害怕，或者以前受过伤害的人，过度分析、心理分析人们的行为并寻找危险信号感觉像是一个明智的决定。这感觉像是一个安全的做法。但我们这样做究竟失去了什么？通过这个视角一直看待约会行为真的有必要、有帮助吗？仅仅因为我们拥有语言，仅仅因为我们理解这些概念，它真的能减少这些人可能只是会出现的事实吗？它真的能增加我们找到符合我们的爱的方式和连接方式的人的机会吗？
It's a very complicated topic, right? In one kind of hand, I do think that our understanding of this language has really helped a lot of people. On the other end, I do think that if you're dating and you're on your 20s or 30s, just because you are intellectually aware of the way that, that people can have difficulties with love or the ways that they can show up. And just because you can intellectualize relationship problems doesn't mean that you're actually solving them, especially when you're at the beginning of a relationship and you don't really know a person well enough to make a call. So even though we feel like this is helpful, is it? And what is it
这是一个非常复杂的话题，对吧？一方面，我确实认为我们对这种语言的理解确实帮助了很多人。另一方面，我确实认为如果你在约会，正处于二十多岁或三十多岁，仅仅因为你在理智上意识到人们可能会在爱方面遇到困难的方式，或者他们表现自己的方式。仅仅因为你能把关系问题理论化，并不意味着你实际上在解决它们，尤其是在关系刚开始的时候，你对一个人还不够了解，无法做出判断。所以尽管我们觉得这很有帮助，但真的吗？它到底在
actually doing to our dating prospects? That is what we're going to explore today. I hope you find this episode informative. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why, we psychoanalyze the people that we date. When we talk about psychoanalizing or over-analizing somebody that we are courting or that we are dating, what we are usually talking about is the tendency to link behavior, everyday behavior, to something deeper, something hidden, something pathological, even, psychological or unconscious. And we often base this explanation on maybe limited. or inaccurate information. It is our tendency to take something they say or do and just dig, dig,
对我们的约会前景做什么？这就是我们今天要探讨的内容。希望您觉得本期节目 informative（信息量大）。废话不多说，让我们进入我们对约会对象进行心理分析的背后的心理学。当我们谈论对我们正在追求或约会的某人进行心理分析或过度分析时，我们通常谈论的是将行为（日常生活行为）与更深层、更隐秘、甚至病理性的、心理的或无意识的东西联系起来的倾向。我们通常把这种解释建立在可能有限的。或不准确的信息上。这是我们的一种倾向，即抓住他们说的话或做的事情，然后深入挖掘、挖掘、
interpret, interpret, look to find a deeper meaning in order to avoid maybe a simpler, more accurate explanation that might hurt our feelings. For example, it might look like assuming somebody is avoidant because they take longer to reply to your messages or interpreting someone's distance as a fear of intimacy when they simply just don't like you back. Like that might be the actual explanation. It can also happen the other way around, right? We might hear that somebody's had a really difficult childhood or had a really tumultuous previous relationship and assume that this will mean they are emotionally unavailable. This will mean that they have a fear of intimacy. when we don't actually have the experience with them yet to make that call and to be able to
解释、解释，寻找更深层的含义，以避免那种可能会伤害我们感情的更简单、更准确的解释。例如，这可能表现为假设某人是回避型的，因为他们回复你的消息需要更长时间，或者当对方只是单纯不喜欢你时，却把某人的疏离解释为对亲密关系的恐惧。这可能才是实际的解释。这也可能反过来发生，对吧？我们可能会听说某人有非常艰难的童年，或者有过非常动荡的上一段恋情，并假设这意味着他们在情感上是不可接近的。这意味着他们对亲密关系感到恐惧。而实际上我们还没有和他们有过这方面的经历来做出这种判断，并能够
actually understand them for all their different nuances. Now, to be clear, as I said in the intro, the words or labels we so often hear around relationships are really important. Things like attachment styles and emotional availability and boundaries and self-sabotage and avoidance, they all describe very real relational patterns that influence people very deeply. We know from extensive amounts of research, literally too many pieces of research to even begin citing, that something like an insecure attachment pattern that was developed in childhood tends to show up when we experience love in adulthood in our 20s and beyond. We know that people
真正理解他们所有的不同细微差别。现在要明确的是，正如我在引言中所说的那样，我们在人际关系中经常听到的话语或标签真的很重要。诸如依附风格、情感可得性、边界、自我破坏和回避等概念，都描述了非常真实的、深刻影响人们的关系模式。我们从大量的研究中得知，字面意思是多到无法开始引用的研究，诸如在童年时期形成的、不安全的依附模式之类的东西，往往在我们成年后（二十多岁及以后）体验爱时表现出来。我们知道人们
who have had traumatic past relationships and relationship experiences, may respond to that by becoming closed off naturally. We know that if someone saw their parents fighting all the time or saw a parent cheat or saw their parents stuck in a really toxic relationship, this can create a belief that love is not safe or that love is not a positive experience and that creates a pattern within them that's not really about them but is and influences how they go out into the world and treat this. people they date, unconsciously or not. But just because we logically know that these things do
那些有过创伤性的过去关系和恋爱经历的人，可能会通过自然地封闭自己来做出回应。我们知道，如果有人看到他们的父母一直在吵架，或者看到父母出轨，或者看到父母陷入一段真正有毒的关系中，这可能会产生一种信念，即爱是不安全的，或者爱不是一种积极的体验，这会在他们内心创造一种模式，这其实并不完全关于他们，但它会影响他们如何走向世界并对待这一点。他们约会的人，无论是否有意。但仅仅因为我们在逻辑上知道这些事情确实
occur and what they look like in relationships and the struggles that they cause does not mean that we should be so quick to pathologize and label every dating behavior through this lens. We need to be aware that a single psychological concept can never be the full explanation of a person. A label is there to describe a patent. It can also flat. experience. It can flatten a person. You know, someone texting slow, could be avoidant, or they could be busy. They could be overwhelmed. They could be unsure. They could be neurodivergent. They could be depressed. They could be uninterested. They could be cautious. Like, there's all these different explanations. We typically just search for the one that fits our past narrative. Someone who
发生过，以及它们在关系中看起来是什么样的，它们所造成的挣扎，并不意味着我们应该如此迅速地通过这个视角将每一种约会行为进行病理化和贴标签。我们需要意识到，单一的心理学概念永远不可能成为对一个人的完整解释。标签是为了描述一种模式。它也会抹杀。经历。它会扁平化一个人。你知道，一个人发信息慢，可能是回避型的，或者他们可能只是忙。他们可能不知所措。他们可能不确定。他们可能神经多样性。他们可能抑郁了。他们可能不感兴趣。他们可能很谨慎。所以，有所有这些不同的解释。我们通常只是寻找符合我们过去叙事的那个。有人
struggles to talk about their feelings may have deep wounds from the past, but they may also have just grown up in a family where they just, this just wasn't normal. There just wasn't that kind of emotional language. It wasn't model to them. Or they may just need time to feel safe and to like really open up about their feelings and about how they feel about you. And that's, again, totally natural. Someone needing space and saying, hey, I just need to back off for a little bit.
挣扎着谈论自己的感受可能有来自过去的深层创伤，但他们也可能只是在一个这样的家庭中长大，这在当时并不正常。那里根本没有那种情感语言。这种模式没有向他们展示。或者他们可能只是需要时间来感到安全，并真正敞开心扉谈论他们的感受以及他们对你的感觉。而这，再次说明，是完全自然的。有人需要空间并说，嘿，我只需要退后一点。
One explanation is that they're emotionally unavailable. They could also be regulating themselves. They could also be actually trying to do what's best by you. They could be trying to maintain healthy independence or move at a pace that feels sustainable for them because they don't want to hurt your feelings, because they're taking this seriously. When we psychoanalyze, what we often do is take a word that's been used in one specific context for one specific thing and we apply it to a lot of other behaviors that, as I said, have a different explanation.
一种解释是他们在情感上不可接近。他们也可能在自我调节。他们也可能实际上在努力为你做最好的事。他们可能试图保持健康的独立性，或者以对他们来说可持续的步伐前进，因为他们不想伤害你的感情，因为他们很严肃地对待这件事。当我们进行心理分析时，我们经常做的是拿一个在一个特定语境下用于特定事情的词，然后把它应用到许多其他行为上，正如我所说，这些行为有不同的解释。
This links to a psychological idea that we know as concept creep. So in a 2016 paper that was published in the Journal of Psychological Inquiry, this psychologist, his name is Nick Haslam, he's from the University of Melbourne. He argued that many harm-related psychological concepts, including terms around trauma, around abuse, attachment styles, mental disorders. They have expanded over time. In some ways, that's been really helpful. In other ways, it hasn't.
这与我们所知的“概念蔓延”这一心理学概念有关。因此，在2016年发表在《心理学探究》杂志上的一篇论文中，这位心理学家，他的名字叫尼克·哈斯姆，他来自墨尔本大学。他认为，许多与伤害相关的心理学概念，包括围绕创伤、虐待、依附风格、精神障碍的术语。随着时间的推移，它们已经扩展了。在某些方面，这真的很有帮助。在其他方面，则不然。
these concepts, many of which began as clinical terms and clinical observations, they get taken out of that context and they start being used, I guess, more freely and being applied to more and more and more things and more experiences and events until their everyday use just doesn't reflect their original meaning. Avoid an attachment is an amazing example of this. When researchers first started investigating this pattern of children relating to their parents and relating to others, they were looking at kids in orphanages. They were looking at kids in foster care. They were looking at children who had been seriously abused. And that's why they were seeing this deep avoidance of connection. Nowadays, it's not uncommon to hear people use it to simply describe someone
这些概念，其中许多最初是临床术语和临床观察，被带出了那个语境，并开始被使用，我想，更加自由地，并被应用到越来越多、越来越多的事情和更多的经历与事件中，直到它们的日常使用根本无法反映它们最初的意义。回避型依附就是这方面的一个极好的例子。当研究人员首次开始调查这种儿童与父母及他人建立联系的模式时，他们调查的是孤儿院里的孩子。他们调查的是寄养家庭里的孩子。他们调查的是遭受过严重虐待的儿童。这就是为什么他们会看到这种对亲密关系的深深回避。如今，听到人们用它来简单地描述某人
who doesn't want a relationship. That's concept creep. And those two things, things are obviously not the same. And if the word we have for the most severe abandonment and attachment wounds becomes the same word we use for personal preferences or for somebody who is just dragging their feet, what word do we use for those extreme cases anymore? Like, what word do we now have to still ensure that the severity of what somebody is experiencing is clear? So that's kind of what we're describing in the kind of, I don't want to say problem behavior, but the problem behavior we're thinking about. Why do we do this? Because it's not always intentional, and it usually stems from a very real and a very sincere place, which is a fearful place. Labels like avoidant, like emotionally
不想谈恋爱，这已经屡见不鲜了。这就是概念蔓延。这两件事显然是不一样的。如果我们用来形容最严重的遗弃和依附创伤的词，变成了我们用来形容个人偏好或只是拖延的人的同一个词，那么我们还能用什么词来形容那些极端案例呢？比如，我们现在有什么词来确保某人所经历的事情的严重性是清晰的？所以这有点像我们在描述的，我不想说是有问题的行为，但这是我们正在思考的有问题的行为。我们为什么会这样做？因为这并不总是故意的，它通常源于一个非常真实、非常真诚的地方，也就是一个充满恐惧的地方。像回避型、情感
unavailable, like codependent, that we can very easily access and use to very easily explain a way or categorize somebody's behavior, they help give us a sense of certainty. when a lot of dating is really, really uncertain. Like, dating someone for the first time, dating somebody new, being interested in somebody is a really vulnerable human experience. And the knowledge that we gained about somebody else and whether they're right for us or whether they have certain quirks, like the knowledge we gain is often slow. It takes time to really see somebody's true intentions.
不可接近、共依赖这些标签，我们可以非常容易地获取并用来非常轻巧地解释或分类某人的行为，它们有助于给我们一种确定感。而很多约会实际上是非常非常不确定的。比如，第一次和某人约会，和新的人约会，对某人感兴趣是一个非常脆弱的人类体验。我们对别人的了解，以及他们是否适合我们，或者他们是否有某些怪癖，这种了解通常是很慢的。真正看到一个人的真实意图需要时间。
To get to understand who they are, what they are, the way they think, whether something's going to work out is a slow process. And our fear wants answers now. Our fear is urgent. The anxious part of us wants to know as soon as possible. Is this person safe? Is this person going to hurt me? Am I wasting my time? It just wants any kind of clarity against the uncertainty of dating. When we simply don't know yet, and all we have is little clues that have kind of put us on edge, we tried to solve it in our own minds through labels and mental shortcuts. There is a really interesting article from this, I can think it's like a center.
去了解他们是谁，他们是什么样的人，他们的思维方式，事情是否会有结果，这是一个缓慢的过程。我们的恐惧希望立刻得到答案。我们的恐惧是紧迫的。我们焦虑的那一部分希望尽快知道。这个人安全吗？这个人会伤害我吗？我在浪费时间吗？它只是想在约会的充满不确定性中得到任何形式的清晰。当我们还不知道，而我们所拥有的只是一些让我们处于边缘的小线索时，我们试图通过标签和心理捷径在自己的脑海中解决它。有一篇非常有趣的文章来自这个，我想它是一个中心。
It's called the Greater Good Science Center, I think at Berkeley, UCLA, one of those. And they wrote this paper titled, How to Stop Oversinking Your Relationships, and it outlines the five types of rumination that takes place in romance. It's blame rumination, control rumination, doubt rumination, worst case scenario rumination, and self-pity rumination. If you are an
它叫做“大善科学中心”，我想在伯克利、UCLA，其中之一。他们写了一篇题为《如何停止过度思考你的关系》的论文，其中概述了恋爱中发生的五种反刍。它们是责备性反刍、控制性反刍、怀疑性反刍、最坏情况反刍和自怜反刍。如果你是一个
overthinker, it's an amazing article. And the biggest one on that list that takes place when we psychoanalyze a potential partner is control rumination. Control thoughts. They orbit a desired future outcome. And they're very obsessed with the best way to achieve it. We want to control exactly how this relationship is going to go. They're also extremely sensitive to any deviations from that plan. Your control rumination is on high alert for anything that is out of the ordinary, anything that's going to hurt us, anything that goes against our desire to control a situation. Instead of simply acknowledging that you like them and that you don't know where this is going and that maybe some of their behavior is a little bit hard to categorize, your control
过度思考者，这是一篇极好的文章。而在我们心理分析潜在伴侣时发生的清单上最重要的一项是控制性反刍。控制性想法。它们围绕着一个期望的未来结果。并且它们非常痴迷于实现这一目标的最佳方式。我们想要精确控制这段关系将如何发展。它们对偏离该计划的任何偏差也极其敏感。你的控制性反刍处于高度戒备状态，警惕任何不寻常的事情，任何会伤害我们的事情，任何违背我们控制情况愿望的事情。你不是简单地承认你喜欢他们，你不知道这会走向何方，也许他们的一些行为有点难以分类，而是你的控制
rumination, your mind starts analyzing, predicting, interpreting, and explaining the reasons behind these very normal feelings through somebody else's behavior. And it feels productive. It feels like the more I think about this, the more answers I'm going to get. And with the more answers I'm going to get, the more certainty I'm going to receive. That's what we're craving. We're not actually craving anymore, the love or the relationship or the slow burn. We're craving the knowing.
反刍，你的大脑开始通过别人的行为分析、预测、解释和解释这些非常正常的感觉背后的原因。这感觉很有成效。这感觉就像我思考得越多，我得到的答案就会越多。而我得到的答案越多，我收到的确定性就会越多。这就是我们渴望的。我们实际上不再渴望爱、关系或细水长流。我们渴望的是“知道”。
This fits in with a much broader area of research on the psychology of uncertainty, which is like one of my favorite things ever to talk about as an unbearable. uncertain person and a very anxious person. In a rather old paper published in 1996, not that old, but old for psychology standards, the social psychologist Krugolanski and Webster, they developed the idea of the human need for cognitive closure. And this essentially refers to the desire for definitive answers to reduce discomfort and ambiguity. They suggested that when people strongly want closure, they may seize an explanation quickly and then freeze around it. And when they freeze around an explanation, they become less open to other interpretations
这与关于不确定性心理学更广泛的研究领域相吻合，作为一个人生无可恋的。不确定的人和一个非常焦虑的人，这是我最喜欢谈论的事情之一。在1996年发表的一篇相当古老的论文中（对于心理学标准来说不算太老，但也很老了），社会心理学家克鲁格兰斯基和韦伯斯特提出了人类对认知闭合的需求这一理念。这本质上是指对明确答案的渴望，以减少不适感和模糊性。他们提出，当人们强烈渴望闭合时，他们可能会迅速抓住一个解释，然后围绕它“冻结”。当他们围绕一个解释冻结时，他们就会变得不那么开放去接受对同一情况的其他解释
of the same situation. In dating, this might look like labeling somebody as emotionally unavailable at the first sign of anxiety because that feels more tolerable than just accepting that you don't really know what they want yet or that you're not that far ahead or down the line to know or that this may just be anxiety that is coming from your own perception, not the reality of the relationship or somebody else's behaviour. All of this is to avoid getting hurt. We're not blaming you. We're just trying to explain it.
。在约会中，这可能表现为在出现焦虑的第一迹象时将某人贴上情感不可接近的标签，因为这比仅仅接受你真的不知道他们想要什么，或者你还没有走到那一步或走得足够远而无法知道，或者这可能只是来自你自己的感知而不是关系或别人行为的现实的焦虑，感觉更具可承受性。所有这一切都是为了避免受到伤害。我们不是在责怪你。我们只是在试图解释它。
giving the person you're dating in a category feels very manageable, feels very stable. It almost feels like the more intelligent way of approaching a situation, rather than simply admitting that you feel scared, rather than simply admitting that, hey, maybe this actually won't work out and there is a possibility that I'm going to be hurt. You don't want to be hurt. You want to avoid that. This is a strategy for doing it. Sometimes trying to delve into their past as well to figure out, like,
给和你约会的人归类感觉非常易于管理，感觉非常稳定。与简单地承认你感到害怕相比，与简单地承认，嘿，也许这真的不会成功，而且我有可能会受到伤害相比，这几乎感觉像是处理情况的更聪明的方式。你不想受到伤害。你想避免这种情况。这是一种实现它的策略。有时试图深入探究他们的过去，以弄清楚，比如，
like, what's wrong with them? Also feels less humiliating that admitting that this connection isn't working out or that it just isn't developing in the way that you hoped. Again, that's a really hard pill to swallow if you really like somebody. Maybe you're right. Maybe they weren't told or made to feel loved when they're a child. And so they do have a very anxious or avoidant attachment style. Maybe their ex really did screw them up and they have a fear of intimacy.
比如，他们有什么毛病？也比承认这段关系没有起色，或者它根本没有按照你希望的那样发展，感觉不那么羞辱。再说一遍，如果你真的喜欢一个人，那确实很难接受。也许你是对的。也许他们在童年时没有被告知或没有感受到被爱，所以他们确实有焦虑或回避型的依附风格。也许他们的前任真的把他们搞砸了，他们对亲密关系有恐惧。
Maybe they just don't have the capacity to love as deeply as you. maybe there is something psychological and pathological about their behavior. But does that really change what is happening right now? Does it help you show up in your best way in this situation? Does it help your heart stay open? Does it help you feel hopeful or open to possibility? Probably not. This becomes, as I said, very intensive you've been hurt before.
也许他们只是没有像你那样深爱的情感容量。也许他们的行为背后确实有什么心理学和病理学的东西。但这真的改变了现在正在发生的事情吗？它能帮助你在这种情况下以最好的方式表现自己吗？它能帮助你的心保持开放吗？它能帮助你感到充满希望或对可能性保持开放吗？可能不会。正如我所说，如果你以前受过伤害，这就变得非常密集。
So often our own psychology is intermingling with our perception of their psychology. if you have dated someone that turned out to be emotionally, like, avoidant, inconsistent, manipulative, or just genuinely unsafe, it makes a lot of sense that you are more alert the next time you date someone. It makes sense that you want to read all the books, know all the concepts, know everything there is to know. We learn from pain, neurologically, psychologically, emotionally, mentally, if something hurt you really badly, at your core, you naturally become quicker to scan for signs that is happening again, sometimes without you even knowing it. The thing is, is that this actually ends up hurting and influencing your own behavior more
通常，我们自己的心理与我们对他们心理的感知交织在一起。如果你曾与一个被证明是情感上的、比如回避、反复无常、操纵性或纯粹不安全的人约会过，那么下一次你和别人约会时更加警惕是完全合乎情理的。你想阅读所有的书，了解所有的概念，了解所有能知道的一切，这是合乎情理的。我们从痛苦中学习，在神经学上、心理学上、情感上、精神上，如果某事深深地伤害了你，在你的内心深处，你自然会更快地扫描这种情况再次发生的迹象，有时甚至连你自己都不知道。问题是，这实际上最终会伤害并影响你自己的行为，超出了
than you really can tell in another rather old but very well-sided 1998 paper that was published in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology. These researchers wanted to kind of prove or provide some evidence for this theory, and they conducted two studies on rejection, sensitivity, and conflict between couples and romantic relationships. They conducted a longitudinal study and they conducted a laboratory study to basically figure out if we enter a relationship scared, does this influence how the relationship's going to work out? We actually featured this study as part of our study of the week series over
你真正能分辨的程度。在另一篇相当古老但被广泛引用的1998年论文中，该论文发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》上。这些研究人员想要证明或为这一理论提供一些证据，他们对浪漫关系中情侣之间的拒绝敏感性和冲突进行了两项研究。他们进行了纵向研究和实验室研究，基本上是为了弄清楚如果我们带着恐惧进入一段关系，这会影响关系的结局吗？我们实际上在几周前的Substack上将这项研究作为我们的“本周研究”系列的一部分进行了专题报道。所以如果你还不是会员，并且想了解他们如何发现或找到这项研究结果的全部细节，你可以去那里加入。但我可以告诉你他们发现了什么。我可以告诉你结论，那就是：那些
on Substack a couple of weeks ago. So if you are not a member and you want to know the full details of how they went about discovering or finding the outcome of this study, you can go and join there. But I can tell you what they discovered. I can tell you the conclusion, which was that people who entered a relationship expecting rejection often exhibited behaviors that the researchers claimed contributed more to a rejecting response from their partner. They were more likely to start arguments. They were more likely to be suspicious. They were more likely to sense rejection in places that it wasn't occurring. And this contributed to a really awful cycle for them where they ended a relationship anticipating that things were going to go wrong. This increased
带着对被拒绝的预期进入一段关系的人，经常表现出研究人员声称会促使他们的伴侣做出更多拒绝反应的行为。他们更有可能挑起争端。他们更有可能产生怀疑。他们更有可能在没有发生拒绝的地方感知到拒绝。这为他们带来了一个非常糟糕的循环，他们带着事情会出错的预期结束了一段关系。这增加了
behaviours that made things go wrong, which therefore made them feel like in the future, relationships were going to always be a catastrophe and the cycle started again. A more recent piece of work actually supports this. This one was conducted in 2023. from researchers at the University of Wollongong and the University of Leeds in Trinity. And it was a massive meta-analysis. It looked at 60 studies involving like 17,000 people exploring the same thing. Does our fear of relationships and fear and relationships create a self-fulfilling prophecy? They found that it did because our fears often shape our behaviors in ways that we don't really know, which in turn shapes our reality. When we are primed to see
导致事情出错的行为，因此让他们觉得在未来，恋爱关系总是会变成一场灾难，然后循环又开始了。最近的一项研究实际上支持了这一点。这项研究于2023年进行。来自卧龙岗大学、利兹大学和圣三一学院的研究人员。这是一项大规模的元分析。它观察了60项研究，涉及约17,000人，探讨了同样的事情。我们对关系的恐惧和关系中的恐惧是否会创造一个自证预言？他们发现确实如此，因为我们的恐惧往往以我们并不知道的方式塑造了我们的行为，而这反过来又塑造了我们的现实。当我们预先倾向于看到
rejection or relationship problems, we are way more likely to interpret such relationship problems from ambiguous cues. And then we behave with fear, often creating more conflict. I think a really key thing here is that this situation often gives us that, I told you so moment. Like I told you this guy was a bad egg. If we predict the behavior or the rejection or the problems and it actually happens, we can turn around and say, see, this intellectualizing I'm doing, the psychoanalysing is helpful. I knew this was going to happen. I need to continue to be on high alert because here's the evidence, not realizing our contribution to the evidence. In reality, I don't think any amount of preparation or prediction for rejection or difficulty in relationship makes it
拒绝或关系问题时，我们更有可能从模棱两可的线索中解释这种关系问题。然后我们带着恐惧行事，往往会产生更多的冲突。我认为这里非常关键的一点是，这种情况经常给我们那种“我早就告诉你了”的时刻。就像我早就告诉你这家伙是个混蛋一样。如果我们预测了行为、拒绝或问题，而它真的发生了，我们可以回过头来说，看吧，我正在做的这种理智化、心理分析是有帮助的。我知道会发生这种事。我需要继续高度戒备，因为证据就在这里，却没有意识到我们对证据的贡献。现实中，我认为任何程度的对拒绝或关系困难的准备或预测都不会让它
any less painful. All it does, as the research suggests, makes it perhaps more likely to get a little bit out of control, or it makes it more likely to come up earlier. Again, is this intentional? Does that mean we are responsible for this person's pain or trauma? And does that mean that pain and trauma can't be overcome? No. It just means that entering a relationship on high alert, thinking it's going to be helpful, often isn't.
变得不那么痛苦。正如研究所建议的那样，它所做的一切，也许只是让事情更有可能失控，或者让事情更有可能更早发生。再说一次，这难道是故意的吗？这是否意味着我们要对这个人的痛苦或创伤负责？这是否意味着痛苦和创伤无法克服？不。这只是意味着带着高度戒备进入一段关系，认为这会有所帮助，通常并不会。
I want to explore this a little bit more and why the narratives we construct about people might not always be accurate after this showbreak. New Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.com. At participating Canadian restaurants excluding Quebec. Hey, this is Hayes, Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook, on the Baxter.
在这段广告之后，我想更多地探讨这一点，以及为什么我们对人们构建的叙事可能并不总是准确的。全新的红牛龙果味和热带果味能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，采用冻干水果制成，带来爆发的电感风味。全新红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳发售。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，McDonald's.com详细信息。在参与活动的加拿大餐厅（魁北克除外）。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特。还有肖恩·克莱门茨。我们在巴克斯特主持播客《好莱坞手册》。
big money players network. Our show is extremely accessible to first time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman. Not that great.
大钱玩家网络。我们的节目对第一次听的听众非常友好。每周，我们都会和演艺界（也就是“圈子”）的人谈论，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能给我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为他们的公关让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多出色的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼。没那么棒。
Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip this script? What is the surprise woman who actually? think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird. Adam Scott, this entire time you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to visit the show. I would never expect, I would never set expectations for something like that to happen.
其实，你能帮我塑造一下这个吗？我们怎么把它翻转过来，对吧？我们怎么把这个剧本翻转过来？那个实际上让人吃惊的女性是？认为自己是直男的那个人其实才是行为古怪的那个人？亚当·斯科特，你一直期待亚当·桑德勒来节目参观。我绝不会期望，我绝不会对这种事情发生抱有期望。
If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm open to it. I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile, masculinity. exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, I was like, is that weed? Nope. It's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? Like, you're like, oh, what's just a state.
如果宇宙允许这种事情发生，我是持开放态度的。我总是会接受的。你知道，丹尼·麦克布莱德，好吧。是的，这全都是这种脆弱的、男子气概。散发出来。老实说，我走过走廊时就能闻到。我想，我就想，那是大麻吗？不。那是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒，不。因为很多时候脱离了语境，人们根本get不到，甚至不知道圆圈是什么。你知道我的意思吗？就像，哦，这只是一个状态。
Everyone's so dumb. And fake. Right. Fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are with. us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinheiro and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I'm I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility.
每个人都太蠢了。而且虚假。对。虚假而且也不感兴趣，或者只是像，哦，我有我自己的生活。我才不管你的生活呢。以及许多其他如果没有我们就不会有今天成就的大人物。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔亲自告诉我们他很喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在是太忙了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在全新播客《独行女子》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我坐他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”的空间。我的使命是重新定义“独行女子”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。
Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months.
每次我试图独自一人时，我总是能遇到人，他们会说，你对我们笑了。这里没有多少人笑。正是在你孤独的时候，你对世界的本来面目最具接受度，而不是对向你兜售的关于世界的谎言最具接受度。这可以是你突破极限、改变想法或唤醒新版本自己的时刻。所以无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是紧张得不敢预定你的第一次旅行，我都希望你在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《独行女子》。在我14岁的时候，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。
I survived and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
我活了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的境遇中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边有一个低沉、嘲弄的声音说：闭嘴，什么也别说。每周，我都会和那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始觉得我的床头有人，然后我开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺了发声的权力。
But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of distance. course. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story.
但这些不是关于被夺走什么的故事。它们是关于为了活着走出来需要付出什么的故事。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《散文社》，这是一档每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是思想女孩、流行文化痴迷者以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等程度关注的人的群聊。当然。我是伊莉莎·拉洛，每周我们都在连接书籍、互联网以及每个人都在不停讨论的话题之间的点点滴滴。我得查查这个故事。
I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is the Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages.
我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和您最喜爱的图书博主到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可能的。就像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的讯息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度探讨、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，你都来对地方了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《散文社》。我们书页之间见。
Psychoanalyzing the people we date as we have explored is a form of self-protection. We know that now. Does it actually protect us? No. I think we may have the label. We may understand the behavior. we may be able to determine where it came from, but we still feel attached to this person. We still feel hurt when it doesn't work out, and we still feel pain.
正如我们所探讨的，对我们约会的人进行心理分析是一种自我保护的形式。我们现在知道了。它真的能保护我们吗？不能。我想我们可能有标签。我们可能理解这种行为。我们可能能够确定它来自哪里，但我们仍然对这个人感到依恋。当事情没有结果时，我们仍然会感到受伤，我们仍然会感到痛苦。
But another reason we may psychoanalyze or overanalyze their behavior is because perhaps when we feel them pulling away, it protects our ego to do so before that reality really takes its shape and really happens. If someone doesn't pursue you in the way that you hoped or is reluctant to kind of define the relationship or maybe doesn't seem so invested, it is really painful to consider that the simplest explanation might possibly be that they just don't like you. Maybe they just, this wasn't going to work out. Those possibilities are really uncomfortable because they require us to feel exposed in a very human way. So then if we assign a psychological explanation to it,
但我们可能对其行为进行心理分析或过度分析的另一个原因是，也许当我们感觉到他们退缩时，这样做可以在这种现实真正成形并真正发生之前保护我们的自负。如果有人没有按照你希望的那样追求你，或者不愿意定义这种关系，或者可能显得没有那么投入，那么去考虑最简单的解释可能仅仅是他们就是不喜欢你，这真的很痛苦。也许他们只是，这不会成功的。这些可能性真的很让人不舒服，因为它们要求我们以一种非常人性化的方式感到暴露。所以如果我们给它分配一个心理学解释，
maybe they're scared of intimacy, maybe their parents really like fucked them up, maybe they like me too much, maybe they're self-sabotaging, whatever it is, that is a much easier pill to swallow because it allows our ego to be protected. It allows us to feel like there was nothing wrong with me, everything was wrong with them. Again, sometimes those explanations might be true, not denying that, but sometimes they merely protect us from the pain of just not being chosen and just not being the one this time, which sucks. It really, really does. Sometimes, and not in all cases, but sometimes this also protects us from looking at our own behavior, which I know is going to be controversial.
也许他们害怕亲密感，也许他们的父母真的把他们弄砸了，也许他们太喜欢我了，也许他们在自我破坏，无论是什么，这都是一个更容易吞下的药丸，因为它允许我们的自负得到保护。它让我们觉得我没有错，错的都是他们。再说一次，有时这些解释可能是真的，并不否认这一点，但有时它们只是保护我们免受未被选择、这次不是那个人的痛苦，这太糟糕了。真的非常糟糕。有时，并非在所有情况下，但这有时也能保护我们免于审视我们自己的我知道这会有争议。
But if we can put everything down to somebody else's trauma or their emotional unavailability or their past issues, we don't have to ask ourselves the big questions we're asking them. Like, did they communicate clearly? did I communicate clearly? Did they overcompensate? Was I overcompensating? Why are they trying to rush intimacy? Was I trying to rush intimacy?
但如果我们能把一切归咎于别人的创伤、情感不可接近或他们过去的阴影，我们就不必问自己我们在向他们提出的重大问题。比如，他们沟通清晰了吗？我沟通清晰了吗？他们补偿过度了吗？我是不是补偿过度了？为什么他们试图急于求成地建立亲密关系？我是不是在急于求成地建立亲密关系？
Like, what about their behavior was I ignoring? What about my behavior was I ignoring? These are huge questions. It's really confronting to realize, hey, maybe I'm not the person I thought I was in a relationship. I think we often engage in this habit of psychoanalizing because it kind of pushes those explanations and the mirror they'll hold up to our own kind of behavior away. Like it makes it not a priority. It's somebody who's done that before I feel quite confident in saying that happens quite a lot.
比如，我忽略了他们的什么行为？我又忽略了我自己的什么行为？这些都是宏大的问题。当你意识到，“嘿，也许我在恋爱中并不是自己以为的那种人”时，这种感觉真的极具冲击力。我认为我们经常陷入这种心理分析的习惯中，因为它在一定程度上把那些解释，以及它们对我们自身行为的反思给推开。就好像这让它不再成为当务之急。作为一个以前做过这种事的人，我很有把握地说，这种情况经常发生。
Like before I met my boyfriend, I was going to say my current boyfriend, my boyfriend. I used to do this all the time. It'd be like, God, he is just so, so insecure. He just has such an insecure attachment style. Meanwhile, I was, like, messaging this man or these men like multiple times a day. I would block them and then unblock them, mute them and then unmute them. The insecure person was me. It was so much easier to say that they were the problem because then there was nothing to fix.
比如在我遇到我的男朋友——我本来想说现男友，就是我男朋友——之前，我以前经常这样做。我就会想：“天哪，他怎么这么缺乏安全感。他的依恋类型怎么这么不安全。”与此同时，我呢，却一天到晚给这个男人或这些男人们发好几次信息。我会把他们拉黑然后又取消拉黑，静音然后又取消静音。缺乏安全感的人其实是我。把他们说成是问题所在要容易得多，因为那样的话，就什么都不用去修复了。
They were unfixable. Whereas if it's about me, I'm responsible for my own issues. I'm responsible for my own problems. I now have to do the work. I also think we often engage in this habit, and this is my final explanation for it, because it also provides us with a social function too. And I really don't see people talk about this. I don't see people talk about how psychoanalysing is a way of bonding.
他们是无法修复的。然而，如果问题出在我身上，我就得为自己的问题负责。我得为自己的麻烦负责。我现在必须得去做心理建设。我也认为我们经常陷入这种习惯，这也是我对它的最后一种解释，因为它还能起到一种社交功能。而且我真的很少看到有人谈论这一点。我很少听到有人讨论心理分析其实是一种建立联系的方式。
Over-analysing people has become, again, part of a shared language within friendships. You go on a date, something confusing happens, something weird, and suddenly, like, the group chat is on fire and, like, everybody's talking about it. Even when we watch, like, reality TV and it's like, this person is acting this way, suddenly we all become psychologists, and it's a fun thing to do. Everyone has a theory. Somebody says they're love bumming. somebody says they're intimidated by you.
过度分析别人已经成为友谊中共同语言的一部分。你约会了，发生了一些让人困惑的事，一些奇怪的事，然后突然之间，群聊就炸锅了，每个人都在讨论。甚至当我们看真人秀之类的节目，然后觉得“这个人表现得是这样”，突然之间我们都成了心理学家，而且这成了一件很有趣的事。每个人都有自己的一套理论。有人说他们在搞“爱意轰炸”。有人说他们对你感到敬畏。
Somebody says, oh, he's overwhelmed by how much he likes you. They say this because they're your friends. They want you to feel good about yourself. And this is part of being there for each other. This is part of bonding is hearing somebody's terrible relationship stories and being like, you're not the problem, they're the problem, here's the explanation. Sometimes the best part of the day is going home and telling the bad stories to our friends, as much as it is telling the good stories to our friends.
有人说，哦，他是被你对他的好感给吓到了。他们这么说是因为他们是你的朋友。他们希望你对自己感觉良好。这也是彼此陪伴的一部分。建立联系的一部分，就是听别人讲述糟糕的恋爱故事，然后说：“问题不在你，问题在于他们，原因在这里。”有时候，一天中最美好的时光就是回家跟朋友们讲讲那些糟糕的故事，尽管这和跟朋友们分享美好的故事一样。
There's a very interesting paper from 2009 by the Belgian psychologist Bernadryne, where he talks about what he called the social sharing function of emotion. He argues that although there has been a shift in modern psychology towards a very individualistic view of emotion and emotional regulation and emotional experiences, when we experience intense things, we naturally want to talk about them. We naturally want to share it with others. We naturally want to unlock and unburden ourselves. And that sharing has a very, very crucial interpersonal and social function. It creates connection. It creates meaning. It brings about support for us. So it makes sense that we want to process dating uncertainty and dating, unfortunate dating stories with friends,
比利时心理学家伯纳德赖恩在2009年有一篇非常有趣的论文，他在其中谈到了他所谓的“情绪的社会分享功能”。他认为，尽管现代心理学已经转向了关于情绪、情绪调节和情绪体验的极度个人主义的视角，但当我们经历强烈的情感时，我们自然而然地会想谈论它们。我们自然而然地想与他人分享。我们自然而然地想释放自己、卸下负担。这种分享具有非常、非常关键的人际和社交功能。它创造了连接。它创造了意义。它为我们带来了支持。所以，我们想要和朋友们一起处理约会的不确定性以及那些不幸的约会故事，这是合情合理的，
even if that means that the theories can get really, really wild and maybe inaccurate. It doesn't really matter at that stage. It just helps us. feel less alone and less pessimistic. The danger in this, though, is that our desire to put somebody else's dating behavior just like through a psychological prism or through a set of psychological criteria actually harms the potential for a relationship to develop naturally, despite perhaps what are early hurdles. Firstly, what would happen if they're doing the same thing back to you as well. Like I spoke about, I've had all these issues in previous relationships, and I always put it on them. And sometimes I think, I'm like, well, if they were doing that same
即便这意味着这些理论可能会变得非常、非常荒谬，甚至可能不准确。在这个阶段，这其实并不重要。它只是在帮我们感觉不那么孤单，不那么悲观。然而，这里的危险在于，我们试图把别人的约会行为置于某种心理学棱镜或一套心理学标准之下的这种愿望，实际上损害了恋情自然发展的潜力，尽管这其中或许存在一些早期的障碍。首先，如果他们也在对你做同样的事情，会怎么样呢。就像我之前说的，我在之前的恋爱中遇到过所有这些问题，我总是把责任推到他们身上。有时我想，如果他们也在进行那种，
psychoanalizing, I wasn't going to come out clean either. Like, I wasn't going to be looking great. So if you're just too complicated people, too interesting, you know, deeply flawed, but deeply loving people in a relationship, and you're both in the early stages, putting the magnifying glass on each other, you're always going to find. find something that is wrong with somebody. You're always going to find some kind of psychological floor. It's just only natural. By both doing that, by one person doing that, like the relationship's done, you'd never date anybody. Secondly, it can also create a confirmation bias, right? It can create this situation where we end up seeing things that just aren't there, but because we've imagined
心理分析，我也好不到哪里去。就是说，我的表现也不会好看到哪里去。所以，如果你和另一个人都是心思复杂、非常有趣、你知道的、有着深深缺陷但又满怀爱意的人，而且你们都处于恋爱的早期阶段，把放大镜对准彼此，你总是能找出对方身上的问题。你总能找到某种心理缺陷。这太自然了。如果双方都这么做，或者哪怕只有一个人这么做，那这段感情就彻底完了，你永远也别想和任何人约会了。其次，它还会产生确认偏误，对吧？它会造成这样一种局面：我们最终会看到那些根本不存在的东西，但因为我们已经想象了，
them or had come in with this preconceived notion, we believe they are. Confirmation bias refers to the tendency to seek, interpret, and remember information in a way that supports what we already believe. It is one of the biggest cognitive traps that humans fall into. Often with things like politics, often with things like prejudices, belief systems, people don't talk about it with dating, but this is a classic example. Basically, if you decide that person you've gone on three dates with, based on what I've seen, they're avoiding it, based on how they're texting me, based on the fact that they were a little bit awkward at the end of the last date, like they're a void and I know it. Once you have that fixed belief or what there was previous psychologists called the
或者带着这种先入为主的观念进入其中，我们便信以为真。确认偏误指的是这样一种倾向，即以支持我们已有信念的方式去寻找、解释和记住信息。这是人类最容易陷入的认知陷阱之一。通常在政治之类的事情上，通常在偏见、信仰体系之类的事情上，人们在谈论约会时不会提及这一点，但这是一个典型的例子。基本上，如果你认定跟你约会了三次的那个人——根据我的观察，他们是在逃避；根据他们发短信给我的方式；根据他们在上次约会结束时表现得有点尴尬这一事实——就像，他们是个逃避型人格，我太了解了。一旦你有了这种固定的信念，或者以前心理学家所称的，
frozen belief, there is nothing else you can see. You are going to look for evidence that they are like that. And you're going to discount any evidence that counteracts that or says something differently. It's not always your choice. This is a cognitive bias. It happens below conscious thought. You know, if they want space, that confirms that they're highly independent and they're going a pull away. If they come closer, you also interpret that as being a negative thing. They're love bumming me. They're coming on really strong. Maybe they can sense that I'm pulling away. When you have a preconceived notion, the theory becomes almost impossible to disprove. In psychology, we say that it lacks falsifiability. You cannot find any evidence contrary to how you already feel.
“冻结的信念”，你就再也看不到别的了。你会去寻找证据来证明他们就是那样的人。而你会对任何反驳这一点或说明不同情况的证据视而不见。这并不完全是你的选择。这是一种认知偏误。它发生在意识思考的底层。你知道，如果他们需要空间，这就证实了他们高度独立，他们会疏离。如果他们靠近，你也会把这解读为一件消极的事。他们在对你进行“爱意轰炸”。他们表现得太强势了。也许他们能感觉到我在疏离。当你有了先入为主的观念时，这种理论几乎就变得无法证伪了。在心理学中，我们说它缺乏可证伪性。你找不到任何与你现有的感受相反的证据。
And this hypervigilance becomes very damaging in the early days of dating because nobody's getting that. Nobody's getting past that. And as we said, because dating is naturally ambiguous, it's just plain awkward. It's, you're just trying to get to know somebody. You don't have the textbook on them. Applying this knowledge prematurely means that nobody is allowed to be imperfect anymore. Nobody is allowed to not be the one from the get-go, and love just doesn't work that way. Even people who actually don't have any flaws, and not to say that psychological relationship patterns is even a flaw anyways, but even somebody who has nothing like that can still come off as if they do because of other things in their lives, like the fact they're busy, like the fact that
而在约会的早期阶段，这种高度警惕会变得非常具有破坏性，因为没有人能摆脱这种状态，没有人能突破这一点。正如我们所说，由于约会本身就具有模棱两可的特质，它本来就是纯粹的尴尬。你只是在试图了解某个人。你并没有关于他们的教科书。过早地应用这些知识意味着再也没有人被允许不完美了。没有人被允许从一开始就不是那个“对的人”，而爱情根本不是这样的。甚至那些实际上没有任何缺陷的人——并不是说心理恋爱模式本身就是一种缺陷——但即使是一个没有这种问题的人，也会因为生活中的其他事情而显得好像有这方面的问题，比如他们很忙，比如，
like their family may be having problems at the moment, like the fact that like, maybe they're just in a weird stage of life. So if we interpret every moment of discomfort as a diagnostic clue, there's no space for connection. Nothing real ever develops. And I also think we miss out on the exciting part about dating, which is the not knowing as well. If you just like fill all the not knowing with descriptions, dating is no longer fun. And dating should be fun. It should be fun. It should be sexy. It should be adventurous. And we kind of lose that. The second thing we lose, as I've also said before, is our own emotional availability. And this is one of the greatest ironies.
比如他们的家人目前可能正遇到麻烦，比如，也许他们正处于人生的一个奇怪阶段。因此，如果我们把每一个不舒服的时刻都解读为诊断线索，那就没有空间去建立连接了。任何真实的东西都无法发展。而且我认为我们也错过了约会中最令人兴奋的部分，那就是“未知”本身。如果你把所有的未知都填满各种描述，约会就不再有趣了。而约会本该是充满乐趣的。它本该是有趣的。它本该是性感的。它本该是充满冒险的。而我们有点失去了这种感觉。我们失去的第二件事，正如我之前也说过的那样，是我们自己的情感可得性。而这正是最大的讽刺之一。
We often psychoanalyze people because we want intimacy to feel safer. But the analysis itself can become that barrier to intimacy that's coming from us, not from them, because it's originating from our own anxiety and from our own need for control. Therefore, we are going to pull back in ways we're imagining they're pulling back. we are going to try and play games as a form of self-protection that we would never like it if they were playing games like I'm only going to message them if they message me first I'm only going to plan the next date if they've planned the last one I'm going to wait exactly as many hours as they did to message me back if you think I'm being hyper-specific here it's because I literally
我们经常对别人进行心理分析，是因为我们希望亲密感能让我们觉得更安全。但这种分析本身反而可能成为通往亲密感的障碍，这个障碍是由我们自己制造的，而不是他们，因为它源于我们自己的焦虑和对控制权的渴求。因此，我们会以我们想象他们疏离的方式来疏离。我们会试图玩心理游戏来作为一种自我保护，而如果他们玩这种游戏，我们绝对会反感——比如“只有他们先给我发信息，我才给他们发”，“只有他们规划了上次约会，我才规划下次约会”，“他们花多少个小时回我信息，我也要等同样长的时间再回”。如果你觉得我这里说得过于具体了，那是因为我真的，
did all of those things I think maturing is realizing maybe you should just message them because you like them enough to risk it. Maybe you should just plan the date because you want to go on a date with this person and it doesn't have to be any more complicated than that. You can just ask them out and maybe you'll get hurt, but also maybe something great will come of it. The thing is when we use the psychological jargon, sometimes this makes us sound very emotionally literate,
把这些事全都做过一遍。我认为成熟就是意识到，也许你直接给他们发信息就行了，因为你足够喜欢他们，值得冒这个险。也许你就该去规划约会，因为你想和这个人约会，事情其实没必要比这更复杂。你可以直接约他们出去，也许你会受到伤害，但也许也会有什么美好的事情因此而诞生。问题是，当我们使用心理学行话时，有时这会让我们听起来很有情商，
but all we're actually doing is avoiding feeling emotionally exposed. And if somebody has attachment issues or, past relationship hurts, they're doing the exact same thing. And we don't ever truly admit how we feel or what we need. And so this essential part of us, like, remains unseen. You know, it lets us feel like we're participating. It gives us the illusion of vulnerability without ever having to risk anything, without ever having to actually be vulnerable, direct, or open about what we want. And there's an interesting contrast here with research on naming emotions, right? Here's where the psychology comes back in in full force. In a 2007 study published in the journal Psychological Science,
但我们实际做的事情，却是在逃避感受情感上的暴露。如果某人有依恋问题或过去的恋爱创伤，他们其实也在做完全相同的事。而我们从来没有真正坦承过自己的感受或需求。因此，我们身上这部分至关重要、本该被看见的东西，却依然被隐藏着。你知道，这让我们觉得自己参与其中了。它给我们一种脆弱的假象，让我们无需冒任何风险，无需真正去展现脆弱、坦诚或敞开心扉去表达我们想要什么。这里有一个有趣的对比，那就是关于命名情绪的研究，对吧？这就是心理学全面发挥作用的地方。在2007年发表在《心理学科学》杂志上的一项研究中，
researchers at UCLA used brain imaging to examine what happens when people put their emotions into words. They found that just labeling negative emotions and just saying, I feel really anxious right now. I'm scared this won't work out. I'm fearful that this person, would just be like the last guy or the last girl or the last person. Just doing that was associated with reduced activity in the amygdala, which is the fear center of the brain. It was also associated with better emotional coping, as well as increased activity in the prefrontal regions, which are involved in regulation and executive functioning. There is such an important and crucial difference between naming our own emotional experience in dating and forming theories about
加州大学洛杉矶分校的研究人员利用脑成像技术，检验了当人们把情绪用语言表达出来时会发生什么。他们发现，仅仅是给负面情绪贴标签，仅仅是说：“我现在真的感到很焦虑。我害怕这不会有好结果。我害怕这个人会像上一个男生、上一个女生或上一个前任那样。”仅仅这样做，就与大脑中恐惧中心——杏仁核的活性降低有关。这也与更好的情绪应对能力有关，同时还伴随着前额叶区域（参与调节和执行功能）活力的增强。在约会时给自己的情感体验命名，与围绕约会中别人的情感体验建立理论，这两者之间存在着一个非常重要且关键的区别。
somebody else's emotional experiences in dating. Noticing that you feel anxious and uncertain can actually help you regulate yourself. Forming a theory around the person you're dating and who they are feels like self-regulation, you are actually just analyzing them. Naming your own emotions brings you closer to your own experiences, whereas analyzing somebody else pulls you deeper into speculation, into uncertainty, because there's never really a correct answer unless you really, really do take the time to know somebody, and pulls you away from actual real connection. This is why when you're spiraling, it's not necessarily helpful to just sit there and wonder what's wrong with them or what happened
注意到自己感到焦虑和不确定，实际上可以帮助你进行自我调节。而围绕着跟你约会的人以及他们是个什么样的人建立一套理论，感觉上像是在自我调节，实际上你只是在分析他们。给自己的情绪命名能让你更贴近自己的真实体验，而分析别人则会把你拉入更深的猜测和不确定性中，因为除非你真的、真的花时间去了解一个人，否则永远不会有一个真正的正确答案，这会把你从真正现实的连接中拉开。这就是为什么当你陷入情绪螺旋时，坐在那里琢磨他们到底怎么了、发生了什么，
or like what they're thinking, the best thing you can do is actually just to sit in that feeling. And the better question to ask is like, why is this triggering me? What about their behavior is hurting me? What can I do with this feeling? How can I manage this feeling in the way that is best for me so that I'm regulated and so that I can find the love that is met for me? Like, that is the better question, putting it back on yourself. we have to remember when we analyze other people we are creating or we're at risk of creating this thing called the parallel mind.
或者他们在想什么，其实并没有什么帮助，你最好能做的，其实只是静静地去体会那种感觉。更好问的问题应该是：为什么这会触动我？他们的什么行为在伤害我？我能拿这种感觉怎么办？我该如何以对自己最好的方式来管理这种感觉，好让我能保持情绪稳定，从而找到属于我的真爱？看，这才是更好的问题，把焦点重新放回自己身上。我们必须记住，当我们分析别人时，我们正在制造——或者面临着制造——一种叫做“平行心智”的东西。
We're going to talk a little bit more about this and also how to stop doing it. Perhaps when you don't even realize you're doing it, which seems like it wouldn't work out, but I promise you we're going to make sure that it's in our conscious state of awareness and something we can actually act on after this short break. Red Bull, Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers. at McDonald's. Made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The
我们接下来会多聊聊这个，以及如何停止这样做。也许在你甚至没意识到自己在这样做的时候，这听觉上好像行不通，但我向你保证，在这段短暂的广告休息之后，我们会确保它进入你的有意识状态，并成为我们可以真正付诸行动的事情。红豆、火龙果和热带浆果能量饮料，麦当劳有售。采用冻干水果制成，带来激爽的活力风味。全新红豆能量饮料，
all-new Red Bull Energizers. Now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details of McDonald's.ca.ca. At participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait
现已在麦当劳发售。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请参阅 McDonald's.ca。参与活动的加拿大餐厅（魁北克省除外）有售。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了作为一名女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我宁愿等
four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here.
四个小时等下一班车，或者让这个路人小哥载我一程摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的能让我不用先征求任何人同意就能说“好”的空间。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用无限可能取代同情。每次我试图独处时，我总是不断遇到人，他们会说：“你朝我们微笑了。这里没多少人会笑。”
It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network.
只有当你孤身一人时，你才是对世界本身最具接收力的时候，而不是对别人向你兜售关于这个世界的谎言。这可以是一段你突破极限、改变想法，或者唤醒一个崭新自我的时光。所以，无论你是一个独自旅行的老手，还是紧张得不敢预订第一次旅行，我都希望你在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。嘿，我是海斯·达芬奇。还有肖恩·克莱门茨。我们是“大钱玩家”网络播客节目《好莱坞手册》的主持人。
Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka The Biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip the script?
我们的节目对第一次听的听众非常友好。每周，我们都会采访一个在娱乐圈工作的人，也就是所谓的“圈内人”，试图帮他们规划职业生涯，看看他们能给我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，也没有人会因为公关让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼，其实也没那么好。实际上，你能帮我梳理一下这个吗？我们怎么把它颠倒过来，对吧？我们怎么把剧本反转一下呢？
What is the surprise woman who actually you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird? Adam Scott. This entire time, you. You've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to visit the show. I would never expect. I have. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm open to it.
那个你以为是直男、其实表现得很诡异的惊喜女性到底是谁？亚当·斯科特。从头到尾，你一直都在期待亚当·桑德勒来做客节目。我绝不会有这种期待。我从来不会对这种事抱有期待。如果宇宙允许这样的事情发生，我是持开放态度的。
I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, I was like, is that weed? Nope. It's fragile. masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know
我总是会接受。你知道的，丹尼·麦克布莱德，也行。是的，这里散发着一种脆弱的男子气概。老实说，我走在走廊里就能闻到。我当时就想，我当时想，那是大麻吗？不。那是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒，不行。因为很多时候脱离了语境，人们根本无法理解，甚至都不知道
what a circle is. You know what I mean? Like you're like, oh, it's so stupid. Everyone's so dumb. And fake. Right. Fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have
什么是圈子。你知道我的意思吗？就像你会觉得，哦，这太蠢了。每个人都好笨。而且很虚伪。没错。虚伪，而且漠不关心，或者只是觉得：“哦，我过我自己的生活。我才不在乎你的生活。”还有许多其他的大人物，如果没有我们，他们根本不会有今天。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔曾亲自对我们说，他非常喜欢这个节目，而且他想成为每一集节目的嘉宾，但他实在是太忙了。请在I Heart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在我14岁的时候，我被绑架并被软禁了九个月。我活了下来，并把我的一生都花在探索其他人是如何在那些本该
destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive.
摧毁他们的事情中存活下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这些是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边传来一个低沉、嘲弄的声音说：“闭嘴，什么也别说。”每周，我都会和那些经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他一定会伤害我。我开始觉得我的床尾站着一个人，然后我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被迫噤声。但这些故事讲的不是他们被夺走了什么，而是讲了为了活着逃出来需要付出什么。
Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsesives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这里是“散文社”，这是一档每周播客，既是图书俱乐部，又是群聊，专为思想深邃的女孩、流行文化痴迷者，以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等程度讨论的人而设。我是伊莉·拉洛，每周我们都在将书籍、互联网以及每个人都忍不住热烈讨论的话题联系起来。我得去查查这个故事。我太痴迷了。从畅销书作家和您最喜爱的图书创作者，到最新的流行文化时刻，一切皆有可能。这就好像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的讯息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。
Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. A healthy relationship, whether it's with a friend, a romantic partner, a family member. It's built through communication. It's built through shared experiences. It's built through empathy.
无论您是在寻找深度文学探讨、聪明的流行文化对话，还是寻找一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，您都来对地方了。请在Iheart radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“散文社”。我们书页之间见。一段健康的感情，无论是和朋友、浪漫伴侣还是家庭成员，都是通过沟通建立起来的。它是通过共同经历建立起来的。它是通过同理心建立起来的。
And crucially, it's built through something called rupture and repair. rupture and repair is this idea that was first posed by the psychologist Edward Tronick in the 1980s that essentially says relationships cannot be amazing all the time we actually need conflict and tension to reveal the things that may not be going right and fix them before they get any worse rupture and repair is how we reestablish trust and connection by splitting and then coming back together and filling that whole with each other. Basically, any relationship, even those in the early days, will have their moments, should have their moments. But overanalysis creates a second relationship, a second mind about the relationship that exists mostly inside your head. It creates a
至关重要的是，它通过一种叫做“破裂与修复”的机制建立起来。“破裂与修复”这个概念最早是由心理学家爱德华·特罗尼克在20世纪80年代提出的，其核心意思是：感情不可能永远都好得不得了，我们实际上需要冲突和紧张来暴露出可能进展不顺利的事情，并在它们变得更糟之前加以解决。破裂与修复是我们通过分离然后重新聚首、用彼此去填补那个空洞，从而重建信任和连接的方式。基本上，任何感情，甚至是那些处于早期的感情，都会有它们的时刻，也应该有它们的时刻。但过度分析会创造出第二段感情，一个关于这段感情的、主要存在于你脑海中的第二种心智。它创造了一个，
parallel relationship, one that isn't actually real, but one in which you are responding from that place. You are not just responding to what is happening, you are responding to what's happening in this parallel relationship. You are responding to what you imagine, they're imagining about this imagined situation, what it resembles from your past, from their past, what your friends think, what a TikTok thinks. All of it is creating this reality that doesn't exist anymore. It's completely detached. And the more time you spend in that parallel world, the less time you spend in the actual relationship, the less time you spend in that repent. stage, not even in that repair stage, but just in that building stage. Soon you're making decisions
平行的关系，一个其实并不真实存在、但你却一直基于那个地方做出反应的关系。你不仅仅是对正在发生的事情做出反应，你还在对这段平行关系中发生的事情做出反应。你正在对你想象中他们对这个想象中的情况的想象做出反应，对它类似于你的过去、他们的过去，或者你的朋友怎么看、抖音怎么看做出反应。所有这一切都在创造一个根本不存在的现实。它是彻底脱离实际的。你在这个平行世界里花的时间越多，你在实际感情中花的时间就越少，你在那个修复阶段——甚至都不是在修复阶段，而仅仅是在那个建设阶段——花的时间就越少。很快你做决定时，
from this place. Again, sometimes your assessments may be correct, especially if you are very emotionally intelligent and very clocked in, but I want to get to this point, which is that it doesn't actually matter. Whether or not your assessment of this person as having this psychological or relationship issue is correct is actually no longer the point. Because knowing that is only helpful up to a certain point. People are not the sum of things that have happened to them. They're the some of the things that have happened to them and how they have responded. They are also their potential to be better in the future.
就会从这个角度出发。再说一次，有时你的评估可能是正确的，特别是如果你情商极高且非常敏锐的话，但我想指出的是，其实这并不重要。无论你对这个人是否具有这种心理或情感问题的评估是否正确，其实已经不再是重点了。因为了解这些只有在一定程度上才有帮助。人们并不是发生在他们身上的事情的总和。他们是发生在他们身上的事情以及他们如何做出反应的总和。他们也是未来变得更好的潜力。
They are also the potential for improvement and to prove themselves to you and to themselves as somebody different. People don't like to be related to as if they are just the things that have happened to them in their past and their potential is done. Even if your analysis is partly accurate, it can be invasive, it can be patronising, and like I said, that's it for that person. You're saying that everything they've experienced before the age of 25 is all they're ever going to be or before the age of 30 is all they're ever going to be. I don't think that's true. A lot of people who have had really deep attachment problems, really deep issues in the past with parents, with exes,
他们也有改进的潜力，向你和他们自己证明自己是一个不同的人的潜力。人们不喜欢被当作他们过去经历的总和、好像他们的潜力已经到头了那样去对待。即使你的分析有一部分是准确的，它也可能是侵入性的、居高临下的，而且就像我说的，这就给这个人判了死刑。你是在说他们在25岁或30岁之前经历的一切，就是他们这辈子的全部了。我认为事实并非如此。许多曾经有很深的依恋问题、过去与父母、前任，
with complex relationships of all sorts, go on and have incredibly healthy relationships. And the people they are in relationships with, do you think that they would have had that if they'd been sitting there and somebody had come up to them with a big rap sheet of everything that was wrong with this person and said, here is every single label that you should know about before you make this choice. Like, we think that more information helps us make a more informed decision about somebody. It actually just overwhelms the part of our brain that is able to look at somebody and see who they truly are beyond this.
或各种复杂关系有过极深问题的人，后来都过上了极其健康的感情生活。而和他们谈恋爱的人，你觉得如果当初有人坐在那里，拿着一张罗列了这人身上所有毛病的厚厚罪状单走过来，说：“这是你在做这个决定之前应该了解的每一个标签”，他们还能拥有那样的感情吗？我们以为更多的信息有助于我们对某个人做出更明智的决定。实际上，这只会让大脑中那个能够看清某人并看到超越这一切的真实自我的部分超负荷。
We think that we're getting to the core. We think that we're getting to the ultimate essential part of who this person is, who they are at their essence. That is like actually means very little. It means very little if somebody is committed to growing, is committed to you, has love in their heart, is trying really hard. This is not an argument for ignoring red flags. I really should say that. It's also not to say that we need to give people the benefit of the doubt, especially if they are demonstrating very harmful or manipulative behaviors. Just get out of there. If they are somebody who has not done the work, doesn't want to do the work, trust your intuition in those situations and, like, trust your assessment of how they are treating you. you. In those cases, pay attention to the labels, pay attention to the psychology of their
我们以为我们在探寻核心。我们以为我们在触及这个人最根本、最本质的部分，即他们本质上是谁。这实际上意义甚微。如果一个人致力于成长、对你忠诚、心中有爱、付出了巨大的努力，那么分析这些就意义甚微了。这并不是在为主动忽视红旗行为辩护。我真的得说明这一点。这也不是说我们需要盲目地给别人无条件的好意，特别是当他们表现出非常有害或操纵性的行为时。直接离开吧。如果他们是那种没有做过心理建设、也不想做心理建设的人，在这种情况下要相信你的直觉，相信你对他们如何对待你的评估。在那种情况下，关注那些标签，关注他们性格背后的心理。
personality. But I don't think that's always the case. Even then, you don't always need to know the deepest psychological reason for somebody's behavior in order to respond to it. This person might not even have a label. They might actually not be anything psychologically wrong with them. It might just be a dick. You do not need to know whether they are hyper-independent and why narcissistic and why traumatized and why just to decide that like this dynamic isn't working and like this person isn't nice to me and I don't feel good like you do not need a diagnosis to leave you do not need to prove somebody is emotionally unavailable to admit that you feel emotionally lonely with them this is what I'm trying to get to the diagnosis that psychoanalyzing understanding intellectually
但我认为并非总是如此。即便如此，为了对某人的行为做出反应，你并不总是需要知道其背后的最深层心理原因。这个人甚至可能根本没有什么标签。他们的心理实际上可能没有任何问题。他可能只是个混蛋。你不需要知道他们是否高度独立、为什么自恋、为什么受过创伤，就能断定这种互动模式行不通，这个人对我不够好，我感觉不好——你不需要一个诊断结果才能离开；你不需要证明某人在情感上是不可接近的，就可以承认和他们在一起让你感到情感上的孤独。这就是我想要表达的——这种诊断，通过心理分析在理智上理解，
why someone behaves a certain way, actually doesn't change the way that we feel. It can just provide further excuses even at that point to push down your feelings or to feel sorry for them or to give them a second chance when maybe you just actually feel awful. Like this is the thing that we're really trying to get to. Sometimes there's actually nothing wrong with this person. They're just not your person. Sometimes there is something wrong with this person, but you could know that regardless. like you didn't need a label to tell you. And sometimes people are deeply hurt, but actually you're the one that is preventing
为什么某人会表现出某种行为，实际上并不能改变我们的感受。它甚至只会在此基础上提供更多的借口，让你压抑自己的感觉，或者去同情他们，或者在明明感觉糟透了的时候还给他们第二次机会。这才是我们真正想要探究的问题。有时候，这个人其实没有任何问题。他们只是不是那个对的人。有时候，这个人确实有问题，但无论如何你都能看出来——你根本不需要一个标签来告诉你。有时候，人们深受伤害，但实际上正是你筑起的高墙，阻碍了本可能发展起来的一段非常健康的感情。是你没有给他们机会。那么，当我们意识到自己身上有这一点、发现自己陷入过度分析的螺旋时，该如何慢下来呢？我们来聊聊吧。作为也曾经历过这些的人，我想我很清楚，
what could be a very healthy relationship from emerging because you're the one with the wall up. You're the one who's not giving them a chance. So how do we slow down when we know this about ourselves, when we find ourselves in an over-analizing spiral? Let's talk about it. As someone who has been in your shoes, I think I know I know how hard it can be.
这种感觉会有多难受。我完全承认自己曾经犯过所有这些毛病，并且觉得这样做能让约会变得更安全。但与此同时，你知道的，也许并没有把聚光灯照向我自己，也没有真正去思考所有这些恐惧和焦虑到底是从哪里来的——其实是来自于我自己的未愈合的创伤。我觉得对我有所帮助的做法，仅仅是说出当下真正发生的事情。也就是，当我发现自己陷入这种情绪螺旋时，我就会对自己说：“我又在进行心理分析了。我又在给那些可能存在也可能不存在的东西贴标签了。我是在拿这个当成他们和我的真实感受之间的缓冲垫。”描述你的这种倾向，回忆你以前做过这种事以及结果如何，并寻找支持你评估的实际行为依据，看看你，
I was guilty on all counts of doing this and feeling like this was going to make dating safer. But then also, you know, not perhaps putting the spotlight on me and not actually thinking about where all this fear and anxiety was really coming from, which was unhealed wounds of my own. I think what helped me was just to name what was actually going on. Like, it was just to say, when I was finding myself in these spirals, I'm psychoanalyzing again. I'm giving labels that may or may not be there. I'm using this as a buffer between them and how I feel. Describing your tendency, remembering times before that you've done this and how it's worked out, and searching for the actual behavioral grounds for your assessment, and whether you,
如果有人在这么早的时候就给你贴上这样的标签，你是否会觉得公平，这能为你提供一些具体可行的事情。从那里开始，你可以问一些相当简单的问题，比如：管它有没有标签，我到底有没有从他们身上得到我真正需要的东西？管它什么心理学不心理学的，他们能满足我的需求吗？他们快乐吗？你没必要把事情搞得太复杂。真的，我总是试图回归简单的真理。
you would think it was fair if somebody gave you this label, this early on, gives you something concrete to work with. From there, you can really ask quite simple questions, which is like, label or no label, am I getting what I actually need from them? Psychology or no psychology, can they meet my needs? Are they happy? You don't have to overcomplicate things. Like, I would always try and come back to simple truth.
不管可能发生或没有发生什么，我对这种行为是否能接受，行还是不行。同样，这里有多种可能性。分析他们、评估他们，会把时间从重要的事情上夺走，而重要的事情其实只是——我的感觉如何？我过去也经常做这样一件事，就像我刚才说的，我会把人静音、取消静音，我会拉黑、取消拉黑，我会做所有这些事情，好把我以为对我不利的人拒之门外，我变得非常着迷，我甚至会去收集他们行为的数据，以此作为他们之所以是这副德行的正当理由。有时候你就是得这样：“我受够了我自己的想象在这里搞出的这些名堂了。你为什么，
It doesn't matter what may or may not be happening. am I okay with the behavior yes or no. Again, there are multiple possibilities. Analyzing them, assessing them, takes time away from the important thing, which is just like, how do I feel? I also used to do this thing where, like I said, I would like mute and un-mute and I would block and I would unblock and I would do all these things to like keep people I thought weren't good for me at bay and I become very obsessional and I would really like almost gather data on like their behavior as justification for why they were the way they were. Sometimes you just got to be like, I'm sick of what my imagination is doing here. Why are you
要表现成这样？”有时候你只是需要说：“好吧，你为什么发个短信要这么久？怎么回事？我要实话实说。”如果你想从他们那里得到诚实，你就需要给他们提供这样一个机会。我记得我曾对我男朋友这么做过，当时我想：“天哪，他一整天都不给我发短信。我知道我以前通过自己脑补空白、告诉自己他们是不成熟的、也许他们其实并不是这样，来毁掉过好几段感情。我这次就试最后一次——我们得尝试点新方法。”所以我直接去问了他，而他的回答是：“我只是，我在上班时不能把手机带在身边。”我当时就想：“天哪，做了那么多心理分析，我压根没想过会是这种回答。”为了一个这么简单的答案，做了那么多的心理分析，
acting like that? Sometimes you just need to be like, okay, why are you taking so long to text me? What's up? I'm going to be honest. If you want honesty from them, you need to provide them with the opportunity. And I remember doing this to my boyfriend and being like, God, he doesn't text me all day. And I know that I've previously self-sabotaged relations. chips by filling in the blanks myself and telling myself that they're emotionally mature and maybe they weren't. I'm just going to give this one shot like, we've got to try something new. And so I just asked him and he was like, I'm just, I can't have my phone on me at work. And I was like, God, all that psychoanalizing and I didn't even think that was going to be the response. Like all that psychoanalysing
简单到大脑根本不会往那方面想。下一步就是去注意这种分析的感觉到底是在保护你免受什么的伤害。在过度分析的背后，通常有一种非常简单的情感或情绪，那就是：我喜欢他们，我想念他们，他们让我想起了某个人，我感到尴尬，我嫉妒，我害怕——而这才是你真正需要去针对的情感。当你直接说出这种感觉时，正如我们之前所讨论的，大脑往往就不那么需要去构建一个复杂的理论，而这反而会妨碍你去处理这种真实的情感。如果承认约会很难，
for an answer so simple, the mind wouldn't even think about it. The next step is just to notice what the feeling of analysis is protecting you from. Underneath over analysis, there is often, a very simple feeling or emotion, which is, I like them, I miss them, they remind me of somebody, I feel embarrassed, I'm jealous, I'm scared, and that is the emotion that you really need to be targeting. When you name the feeling directly, as we talked about before, the mind often has less of a need to build an elaborate theory, which takes away from addressing the feeling. It makes it so much less complex. if we just admit that dating is hard,
而这正是那些让人觉得格外艰难的时刻之一，事情就会变得简单得多。从那里开始，你可以把注意力更进一步地向内转，问问自己：“我到底害怕会发生什么？我感到害怕，我感到恐惧。为什么这是一种糟糕的感觉？我是不是在试图预测未来，这样我就不用再有这种感觉了？或者我试图去分析，真的能帮到忙吗？”把你的注意力重新转回到自己身上，
and this is one of those points where it feels a lot harder. From there, you can turn your attention even further inwards and ask yourself, what am I afraid will happen? I feel afraid, I feel scared. Why is that a bad feeling? Am I trying to predict the future so I don't have to feel this way anymore? Or would me trying to analyze and actually help? Turn your attention back in on yourself
花一秒钟想想你自己的需求，到底什么才能真正帮到你调节情绪？是的，你可能知道自己的感受。你可能知道他们行为背后的简单答案。你现在究竟需要什么？去寻找一致性。把他们此刻的行为看作不仅仅是一个背景故事、不仅仅是心理学、不仅仅是一个需要去解决的问题，而是一个事实。我想这句话我可能已经用无数种不同的方式表达过了，但归根结底，如果他们对你很差，那么到底有没有一个分类来定义他们对待你的方式，其实根本不重要。所以，如果你从自己的感受中找到了证据，证明你并不快乐，这就是答案。而接下来要做的事就是：
and think of your own needs. for a second, what is actually going to help you regulate? Yes, you might know how you're feeling. You might know the simple answer for their behavior. What do you need right now? And look for consistency. Like, look at their behavior right now as more than a backstory, more than psychology, more than something to solve, and just as a truth. I think this is a thing I've probably said, like, the same thing in a million different fonts, but like, it doesn't actually matter at the end of the day if there is a category for how they are treating you, if they are treating you badly. So if you have evidence in your feelings that you are not happy, that is the answer. And now the next thing to do is to be like,
“好吧，我要让自己在这里脚踏实地，我要为自己去做我需要做的事。我不需要标签。我甚至可能不需要跟别人讨论这件事来寻求标签。他们并没有让我觉得开心。我要如何才能让自己开心起来？无论有没有他们。我是要沟通解决，还是离开这种状况去寻找更好的人？”我认为，与心理分析保持一步之遥的另一个神奇之处在于，它实际上能为你节省时间。我觉得所有那些复杂的事情都退场了，你更能游刃有余地说：“这其实不是我想要的。这其实不是我此刻需要的，我要做出那个决定。”再说一次，心理分析的全部意义在于，
okay, I'm going to ground myself here and I'm going to do what I need to do for myself. I don't need a label. I might not even need to talk about this with somebody else who could give me one. They're not making me feel good. How am I going to go about feeling good? With or without them. Am I going to communicate it or am I going to exit this situation and find somebody better? I think the other amazing part about taking a step away from psychoanalizing is that it actually just saves you time. Like I think all the complicated stuff just kind of rolls back and you are so much better able to just be like, this isn't actually what I want. This isn't actually what I need right now, and I'm going to make that call. Again, psychoanalysing is all about
好的，我要在这里站稳脚跟，做对我有益的事。我不需要标签。我甚至可能不需要跟别人谈论这事而让他们给我贴标签。他们让我感觉不好。我要如何让自己感觉好起来？无论有没有他们。我是要沟通，还是要离开这种情况去找更好的人？我觉得抽离精神分析另一个神奇的地方在于，它实际上能为你省下时间。就像我觉得所有复杂的事情都退去了，你能更好地直接说：这其实不是我想要的。这其实不是我现在需要的，我要做出这个决定。再说一次，精神分析全都是关于
uncertainty management, and it's all about predicting what you need, want, can expect in a relationship. The other great way to be certain is to just make decisions based on your gut instinct and to just make the decision when you know you need to make the decision. I think often we talk about this with our friends. We talk about things with our therapist, which you should do, but we overanalyze, we talk about it because we actually want a different answer or want a different outcome to the one that we are experiencing, right? We already know the truth of this. We know the truth of their behavior. The most certain thing you can do is to just do something about it. And if you're really worried about like, am I going to get hurt? Is the person going to hurt me? Sometimes it's better just to be
不确定性管理，这完全关乎预测你在亲密关系中需要什么、想要什么以及能期待什么。获得确定性的另一个绝佳方法，就是完全根据你的直觉做决定，在你知道必须做决定时果断地做出决定。我想我们经常和朋友讨论这些。我们和治疗师谈论这些，你也确实应该这么做，但我们过度分析，我们之所以讨论这些，是因为我们实际上想要一个不同的答案，或者想要一个与我们正在经历的不同的结果，对吧？我们内心其实早就知道真相了。我们知道他们行为背后的真相。你能做出的最确定的事情，就是直接采取行动。如果你真的很担心：我会被伤害吗？这个人会伤害我吗？有时最好就是
like, I'm going to take the evidence I have and let myself get hurt, maybe, accept the certainty that that is part of love, or instead of going to a million people hoping a different thing when I already know what the thing is, just accepting that this isn't working and making the call for myself. What all of this comes back down to is trusting that you are going to be okay without this person. You are going to be okay if this person doesn't accept you. you're going to be okay if this person does and maybe has things in their past. That is like something we mentioned before that is so critical. So many people out there have deep issues.
这样想：我要接受我目前拥有的证据，让自己受点伤也无妨，接受“受伤是爱情一部分”这份确定性。与其去找一百万人，寄希望于从他们那里得到不同的答案，而其实你心里早就知道答案是什么了，不如直接接受“这段关系行不通”这个事实，为自己做出决定。这一切归根结底，是要相信没有这个人你也能过得很好。如果这个人不接受你，你会过得很好的。如果这个人接受了你，但或许他的过去有些故事，你也依然会过得很好。这就回到了我们之前提到的、极其重要的一点。外头有太多人都有着深层的心理创伤。
It's actually not about that. It's about whether they are willing to work on this relationship with you. And it's about whether they make you feel safe. Because somebody with the most intense relationship trauma you can imagine, like if they do the work, if they go to therapy, if they really sit with their pain and sit with their own feelings about it and if they really have awareness about it, could probably show up in a relationship much better than somebody who hasn't had any of their trauma, but just like doesn't have any responsibility.
其实问题不在于此。关键在于他们是否愿意和你一起经营这段关系。关键在于他们是否能让你感到安全。因为一个有着你能想象到的最严重关系创伤的人，如果他们愿意努力，如果他们去接受治疗，如果他们真的去正视自己的痛苦和内心的感受，并且对此有着清醒的认知，那么他们在一个亲密关系里表现出来的状态，很可能比那些根本没有任何创伤、但却完全不愿承担任何责任的人要好得多。
So I think that's like the perfect way to finish this episode. All the language in the world isn't going to help you predict or ascertain or make any promises about whether a relationship is going to work out or not. The only thing you can do is trust that you are going to be okay. Put the spotlight back on yourself and assess how maybe your emotional unavailability or issues is being projected into the relationship and do something about that instead. And then also just stay open to the fact that love and people can change and the right person will make you feel good about yourself.
所以我觉得这是为本集节目画上句号的完美方式。世上所有的语言，都无法帮你预测、确认或做出任何承诺，来保证一段关系究竟能不能走到最后。你唯一能做的，就是相信自己会没事的。把聚光灯转回到自己身上，评估一下你身上是不是有什么情感上的疏离或问题被投射到了这段关系里，然后针对这些问题采取行动。此外，还要对“爱和人是会改变的，对的人会让你对自我感觉良好”这一事实保持开放的心态。
the right person will not have you overanalyzing and psychoanalyzing every single little thing they're doing in search of answers because they'll just be frank with you about what's going on in their mind. So thank you for listening to this episode. Slightly rambly, I know, I had a lot to say. You can always tell the episodes where I have a personal experience with it because I go very off script. So hopefully that's the kind of thing you enjoy and we gave you enough psychology to really back it up. Thank you to our researcher. Speaking of Psychology, Libby Cobbett for her assistance with this episode. If you want some further research or to look at some of the research that we did use for this episode, it's in the episode description down below. You can also follow us on Substack. That
对的人不会让你过度分析和心理剖析他们做的每一个细微动作来寻找答案，因为他们会坦率地告诉你他们心里在想什么。谢谢大家收听本期节目。我知道稍微有点东拉西扯，因为我要说的话实在太多了。你总能听出哪些节目我是有切身体会的，因为那些时候我完全脱稿了。希望这是你喜欢的那种类型，而且我们也提供了足够的心理学知识来支撑这些内容。感谢我们的研究员（说到心理学），Libby Cobbett为本集节目提供的协助。如果你想做进一步的研究，或者查看我们本期节目使用的一些研究资料，它们就在下方的节目简介里。你也可以在 Substack 上关注我们。那篇
study of the week, the one about rejection sensitivity is currently up there right now. And if you relate to rejecting people before they reject you, it's definitely a critical one to read. there are so much more information down below for you to explore, but I do just hope this has helped you understand your own patterns first before you try and interpret others. Second, and if you did enjoy this episode, leave a five-star review, leave a comment down below if you're listening on Spotify, and make sure that you check out on an episode on Netflix. It does help us out a lot. It's a new thing for Netflix, and maybe you didn't even know that we're on there now, but yep, we are, and I don't really know what else there is to say about it. It just really helps us that they know that people like
每周研究文章——关于拒绝敏感性的那篇现在就在上面。如果你发现自己也有“在别人拒绝你之前先拒绝别人”的倾向，那绝对是一篇非常值得一读的文章。下方还有更多信息供你探索，但我真心希望这期节目能帮你做到：首先，在试图解读他人之前，先理解你自己的模式。其次，如果你确实喜欢这期节目，请留下五星好评，如果你是用 Spotify 听的，也可以在下方留言，并且一定要去看看 Netflix 上的节目。这真的对我们很有帮助。这是 Netflix 的一个新功能，也许你甚至都不知道我们现在已经上线了，但没错，我们的确在上面，而且我真的不知道还能说些什么了。这真的对我们很有帮助，因为他们能知道人们喜欢
this podcast and are willing to watch it. So thank you again. I hope you enjoyed. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport and Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Each week, we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam, Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stillard, and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts,
这个播客并且愿意观看它。再次感谢大家。希望你们喜欢。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特和肖恩·克莱门茨。我们是播客节目《好莱坞手册》的主持人。每周，我们都会邀请一位娱乐圈的人士，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，并看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，也没有人因为他们的公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们邀请过许多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼、亚当·斯科特、丹尼·麦克布莱德、本·斯蒂勒，以及许多其他如果没有我们就不可能有今天成就的大腕。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts
or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silent. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive.
或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我曾在被囚禁九个月后幸存下来，我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在那些本该毁灭他们的事情中生存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都和那些经历过难以想象之事的幸存者在一起——被绑架、被跟踪、被控制、几乎被剥夺声音。这些故事讲述了要付出什么才能活着逃脱。
Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space. where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听由伊丽莎白·斯玛特主持的《幸存者档案》。在全新播客《独行侠》（Solita）中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以在下一个车站等上四个小时，或者这个随意的老兄主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项 B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的私密空间，在那里我可以说“好”，而不需要先征求任何其他人的意见。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用无限可能取代同情。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。
Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America, plays out in one small town. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is Our Town, a podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. I guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home.
我们的家乡可不是试管。距离纳什维尔东北九十英里处，一场关于美国未来的争夺战在一个小镇上演。有着右翼背景的开发商购买了数百英亩的土地。我们需要山巅之城。这就是《我们的家乡》，这是一档关于一个小镇成为社会实验场地并奋起反抗时会发生什么的播客。我想你们搬进来时没料到会碰上一群乡巴佬吧，对吧？在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们的家乡》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。
Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to pro-society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Pro Society》是一档每周播出的播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊，适合所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等程度探讨的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、图书创作者以及海量的过度思考观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴联系起来。对，我着迷了。我真的着迷了。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。